good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy monday hope everyone
had a great weekend i am honored humbled
excited and just
beyond relieved to have my co-host back
jackie thank you so much for being here
i cannot tell you how much i've missed
you you're so welcome why don't you why
don't you sit this one out you know
chill enjoy this was such a big weekend
like on all fronts so many holidays
coachella so much to discuss so i feel
very good about being here on a monday
no we needed you today yeah there's so
much to talk about i know i was glued to
my phone this weekend and i didn't
i don't i didn't expect that for myself
like i've been very you know out
disconnected disconnected from what's
going on in the world and i didn't think
that i would be like so obsessed glued
to what was going on at coachella this
weekend but i did not turn my tv on once
that's also because i opted to read this
weekend instead of watch tv but i also
was realizing i was on my phone the
whole weekend like wanting to see the
looks wanting to see what was happening
and we will be recapping all of it but
how was your weekend it was good you
know it was a holiday so it was
um a different kind of weekend for me
i'm not usually like you know
spending the entire weekend like not
drinking you know with family but it's
nice to know it's actually crazy how
long the weekends are when you're not
like going hard yeah
yeah much longer than i was used to and
you're not waiting for your hangover to
pass you're not like wishing away hours
yet are precious no it's true it's 100
true so it felt like a really long
weekend it was good to be close to god
close to family yeah you hosted a
beautiful seder on friday night thank
you yes harold loved it he the reviews
were rave he saw your apartment he said
it was stunning he loved what you did
with the place
and the food was delicious he said
compliments to the chef
and it was a really nice evening thank
you so much yes oh my god that feels
like one eternity ago yeah um but yes i
hosted a seder and then we did the
second seder with ben's family so it was
nice nice holiday um i'm on what is it
now day like three or four of not eating
bread it's a part of the jewish holiday
for those who don't know and i'm
struggling i'm so constipated i've eat
so much matzah which really blocks you
up like if you ever have you know what
when i had the stomach flu i should have
started eating matzah because that would
have bound me up real tight i'm so i'm a
little like on edge because i haven't
had pasta or pizza
in like three or four days and i'm just
we have to go until i think sunday this
week i'm [ __ ] starving like i'm
really hungry damn okay well don't take
it out on me no i act like i'm really
hungry busting my ass to get here i've
pumped like a million [ __ ] times i
woke up so early i literally my eyes are
like watery and whenever i watch the
show back after i've been on because you
know that's a fun thing to do it's a fun
thing to do when you're not doing it
every day every single day
um you can like see the glassiness in my
eyes you look great
thanks girlie and it's not glassiness in
your eye you've just got a sparkle in
your eye that's just something cute
about me you're just that girl i am that
girl yes
so i'm sorry that you can't have your
pizza and pasta i mean neither can i but
it hasn't really impeded what i've been
eating the last few days like i was just
like on a potato kick anyway right
potatoes are the saving grace of pesach
potatoes chips and french fries right
because everything like i want to eat is
humates is the technical word for those
who don't know you can't eat like any
basically gluten yeah kind of um
because you know the jews ran out of
egypt to escape slavery and they didn't
have time for their matzo to rise so
that's why they're bred to rise so
that's it became matzah like a cracker
because the yeast did arise so now to
remember the suffering of our ancestors
for like eight days we can't eat any
gluten and i'm upset and the only thing
that brings me solace is a french fry
because it's not i mean technically if
they're battered in like
tech like
if you want to get technical which i
don't i don't i want to be clear i'm not
getting technical like some people will
not have a found soda because the syrup
in fountain soda is like corn syrup or
whatever i'm not that girl like i will
be having fountain soda but i'm doing
the basics like obviously i'm not
slapping you know a piece of bread into
my mouth of course and i don't want to
get technical at all and i often don't
and i i believe that if moses had access
to french fries like he would have
grabbed a handful i also think like if
he had a bag of pretzels he would have
taken them for the road obviously moses
was a smart man so like some of these
conveniences like i think it's
disrespectful to eat a flat out piece of
bread because moses couldn't right and
moses didn't and then we would be like
rubbing our bread in moses's face and
that's not cool 100
but moses would have grabbed a pretzel
rod if he had one no and if there was
like a 7-11 on the way out of egypt i
know moses would have stopped for a
fountain soda and therefore so will i
100
i just think to myself before i put in
my mouth what would moses want and i
know moses wouldn't want me to suffer so
i
i'm struggling yeah but like the pasta
it does take time to cook moses couldn't
no of course of course so like the
obvious ones but like you know some
people will you know depends on your the
varying levels of religiosity but like a
lot of people will do potato vodka which
is like a special um kosher for passover
vodka because i guess vodka's made from
wheat but i just know moses was like
yeah give me a shot no moses was like
belvedere check yeah no shots for
everyone in shots if he had it in the
house right in him go grocery shopping
why should i suffer no no no so i'm like
so hungry i had like i'm just been
eating like chicken like i'm just so
hungry i'm so sorry no it's okay it'll
be fine then we don't have a big meal
we're like four or five we're like we're
like we're almost halfway almost yeah
and that's good and you have like
chocolate matzah yeah and a lot of
people are giving up different things
for lent so it's like we're all in the
same boat yes agreed so
crazy weekend here to discuss and recap
of it all the revolve of it all oh my
god yes so the revolve of it all so much
to say do you want to wait till first
story which is like really coachella
yeah but tell me about harry how is he
doing everything is good um i can't
believe i don't know the last time i've
been on the show like the days go by so
quickly and i'm like i was just here
right i was just doing the toast and it
was i think like six days ago you were
here last tuesday okay i don't have too
many updates for everyone but things
have been going well breastfeeding is
going really well
and
that's it's all good i mean i'm so
[ __ ] tired all the time yesterday i
guess was like maybe a growth spurt but
he was just like cluster feeding all day
i was literally breastfeeding every hour
and the thing about like you're supposed
to technically you do like every two and
a half to three hours when it's a normal
stretch but that doesn't include the
time spent breastfeeding so if you're
like breastfeeding for around like 40
minutes and the next one that's 40
minutes into the two and a half three
hours yeah it's from start to start so
it's like
it's literally every hour that's [ __ ]
up it's messed up yeah
it should be from the end but obviously
baby's hungry so like why are you gonna
let the kid cry while you just sit there
just make a point
just because like you think it should be
longer speaking of my child you know i
don't want to worry everyone but theo
has been rather ill um and he's going to
the doctor today so just prayers
positive thoughts up for theo prayers up
for theo hopefully everything's okay
it's just like a routine stomach flu but
he's just
unwell and he's not one to complain and
he is like he's strong you know he's
built like
what's the phrase we always say
strong light bulb strong leg ball he is
strong like bull and so if he's down
down and out for the count then
something is a miss i know so like now
we have to i'm like the type of dog but
i'm like it's fine it's fine but then
it's like four or five days where he's
not fine and usually when i'm like he's
fine he is fine and daily you know bryce
has so many days like that right but now
it's like enough time has passed like he
really needs to see a doctor so that and
i have like theo's stool sample like
sitting on my dining room table i don't
know what to do with it i double bagged
it and i put frame it obviously
a double bag
that's one of the sponsors today
i double bagged it and i put in a ziploc
bag and i was like do i put this like in
the freezer like i wasn't sure where to
put it
i think you leave it out yes because
it's chilly sometimes you send this to a
sample like through the mail and it's
not
it's not frozen yeah no so i just have
to hang on to it until 3 30 when he goes
to the doctor okay that's what i'll be
doing today that's really fabulous
gorgeous this fabulous life of claudia
the fabulous stool of theo's offer
beyond fabulous stunning um okay so i
feel like let's just get into it because
like sitting here not talking about
revolve fest is just wasting my time
okay so without further ado
prayer is up for do i know you guys
don't like when i talk about doing it
when i say do to do
today is an important day for you so
everyone just keep doing your thoughts
and bryce he's doing things by the way
happy for you so [ __ ] cute
without further ado it is time for the
past high stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
today's also monday which means we are
on burning or unburdening ourselves at
the end of this episode and the
submissions today are on another level
so i'm excited for that and today's show
is brought to you by skylight nowadays
staying in touch with those we love is
more important than ever and the
skylight digital photo frame makes it
easy you can either email photos to it
or upload them to your app anytime from
anywhere it's a great way to feel close
to those you love even when you're far
away anyone in the family can send
photos to the frame so it's a great way
to keep family members in touch it sets
up effortlessly in under 60 seconds and
even the least tech savvy person can use
it it looks like a real photo frame and
adds a beautiful touch to your home it
has a gorgeous 10-inch touchscreen where
you can swipe through the photos with
your finger and you can even tap to
thank the person who sent the photo with
mother's day coming up you guys are
always asking for the skylight frame so
listen they have 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee so if you don't
love the skylight they'll give you a
full refund you can pre-load the photos
with your favorite photos for mother's
day you can surprise your mom with the
photos that they didn't even know that
you had moms are always like
screenshotting instagram like you could
just make it so easy for them
to have a gorgeous photo of you your
family your friends in their home
as a special holiday offer you can get
the ten dollars off of your purchase of
a skylight frame when you go to
skylightframe.com and enter code toast
that's right ten dollars off your
purchase of a skylight frame when you go
to skylightframe.com enter code toast
that's s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t
f-r-a-m-e dot com and that code is toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by fit on the number one premium fitness
app and it is redefining the workout
experience
so fit on workouts are always free to
use they offer workouts for all fitness
levels that are super easy to follow and
you can access over a thousand workouts
anytime anywhere with fit on they have
workouts as short as five minutes so
there's no excuses to skip a workout and
over 10 million people have already used
it so you know that you're in good
company
whether it's strength training toning
pilates yoga kickboxing you'll never get
bored and you can stream it on your tv
or your laptop so if you're traveling
you can do it in a hotel room if you're
working from home you can do it from
home in between meetings you could take
classes with world-class trainers
trainers like cassie ho jeannette
jenkins and caroline pierce they've been
featured in forbes us weekly people
women's health and more jackie i know
you've had a very positive experience
with fiton can you tell me about some of
the workouts you tried yes i love fit on
i mean i'm looking for all these
different you know classes or things
that i can do at home that are easy that
are effective that really like target
your target areas and i think fidon is a
great resource for anyone who's trying
to get in at home workouts join the over
10 million people getting their fit on
work out for free anytime anywhere text
toast to 64 000 to join fit on for free
that's toast t-o-a-s-t to 64 000. that's
toast to 64 000. all right let's dive
into like what we need to talk about
coachella weekend one the only weekend
that matters well you know what like
this has been such a [ __ ] of an
ex like a a weekend i actually think
that if you were going to coachella like
to enjoy the festival like go to weekend
two oh yeah but as far as like
celebrities parties what not influencers
it's weekend one that all happens but i
agree like if i were if it were like
stagecoach and there were two weekends
and i just really want to see like luke
homes and enjoy my life i would go the
second weekend 100
people forget there's even a second
weekend of coachella right because
everyone activates in the first weekend
and after two years of putting it off
there was a lot of activations to be had
and it was like kind of chaotic yeah i
mean just like on the base level like i
was watching tick tocks of people who
you know bought tickets whether it was
general admission or vip who showed up
to the festival and were turned away
like that they were at capacity what
yeah which is like if you're paying for
a ticket that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
i didn't see that i haven't seen any
tick tocks any other than like what
you've sent me right i feel like i could
have probably had way more coachella
content if i was on tick tock and i
thought about it but i was like no i
will stick to instagram stories and the
people who i'm following who are there
showing me the way so let's talk about
the positives first i have to say i've
been to coachella i've experienced
coachella so i really didn't have a ton
of fomo because no fomo here because
once you've been like you know um but i
did think that the harry styles
performance was everything of the sort
and that's something i would have liked
to see even though like if you've been
to coachella you know like watching it
on a live stream is so much more of a
pleasant experience you really can't see
anything at coachella it's like chaotic
yeah
his performance looks great i had no
fomo when i was like watching everything
through my phone it was just like out of
sheer curiosity and also like after two
years of it being postponed to postpone
i was so curious to see like all the
looks and the fashion because i do feel
like coachella even though it's like so
extreme like
you do get a lot of like fashion info
for it and like if there's a trend
that's hitting like people go all out
and you can see like what are the
obvious trends
the fashion
so this was really surprising there was
very few looks or people who i was like
oh that is adorable no i know everyone
just looked kind of like silly with like
just so many accessories and then like
seeing haley bieber and kendall walk in
and like literal t-shirts and shorts
just like how a music festival should be
enjoyed like casual it's like low-key
very
they made everyone else look so dumb
like you're wearing a thousand hats and
rhinestones and sheer and and necklaces
and like the coolest people are just
wearing like like tank tops and denim
shorts jeans and a t-shirt right it was
like kind of sad yeah and i thought that
was going to be the vibe for this year
like kind of paring everything down and
just like really casual i don't i i
think it's like a tick tock aesthetic
like cool girl look or something uh okay
yeah you know where it's just like haley
bieber style pull back
and we got some of that but we mostly
got just like
discarded looks from three years ago
yeah it was it was all over the place
and there was no clear theme of like
what is the current style and maybe
that's a sign of the times or like
nobody knows how to dress anymore right
and and i think when it comes to
coachella specifically i think people
are just like throw the more [ __ ] on the
better more fringe more beads more chats
more everything and it they just looked
kind of like
clowns yeah
i'm gonna be honest with you guys
you look like [ __ ] clowns two years
of wearing sweats like i think people
just forgot our little rusty yeah there
were some really good looks so i'm not
saying this about everyone but in
general like there was no clear theme
that emerged trends that emerged you
know which the things you wish you would
have worn yeah yeah oh yeah there was
nothing that i was like oh that's what i
would have worn if i were there right
now revolve is really like the center
the center of coachella they've done a
really good job for themselves of like
being the place for clothing the place
for a good time the place for the famous
people even kim showed up yeah and you
know i actually saw this tick tock um i
guess revolve had this deck that they
had
sent around internally just of their
coachella strategy and it leaked somehow
it was really interesting like how most
um
retail brands will consider q4 their
highest time of year because of holiday
sales um
coachella q2 is actually revolves
highest grossing time of year because
there's no sales going on but all these
influencers they give away like a bunch
of free clothing but all the influencers
wearing clothes from from coachella is
their like their top source of revenue
throughout the year i mean that makes so
much sense the amount i mean my whole
feed is revolving and that's why they
can afford to spend millions and
millions of dollars putting on revolve
fest for and for those who don't know
people seem to be very confused it's not
even a part of coachella when you go to
coachella you know the smaller acts the
lesser-known artists will play during
the day and then starting at like seven
o'clock are like people you've heard of
so a lot of people don't even go to the
festival until dark and during the day
there's like not that much to do except
like hang out your house and swim so
revolve had this great idea to put on
their own mini festival during the day
when people usually aren't at the
grounds yet yeah but it's mostly for
like celebrities influencers but now it
is so big i mean it looks like there
were thousands of people there post
malone perform like it is a festival
unto itself they also double the size
when we were there is that confirmed no
i'm just guessing no but it's at the
same place i know but i think in terms
of people and i think but i think that's
also because like post malone performed
like and they always have performers and
stuff but like their headliner like
rivals coachella
yeah and it's it is up until recently
was invite only so you were invited by
revolve either because you're an
influencer or a celebrity or for
whatever reason but this year they
actually got a lot of heat before
coachella even happened because this
email went around to a bunch of people
that they shared on social media that
was offering them an invite to revolve
fest but in order to get invited you
have to spend 2000 on the website so
it's like
okay and a lot of people said that was
like greedy or whatever and then now
knowing what actually ended up happening
at revolve fest people who did pay 2 000
on the website to not even be able to
get in like that sucks
yeah is that what so i want to talk
about like the viral tick tocks i didn't
see anything and i feel like i even got
an email like um
inviting invite like just
like flagging revolve festival if you're
going to be there like let us know
because now i'm like here at bestie it's
back
if you're interested in attending they
say this kindly note this form does not
guarantee entrance to revival festival
an official invite will be sent once
your form has been submitted and there's
nothing about spending two thousand
dollars but maybe different information
different tiers and also i have to like
submit my thing and then maybe they
would get backed right with something so
it takes place at the merv griffin
estate which is an iconic real
housewives of orange county reference if
you know you know um and basically if
you were staying at the
festival with revolve they had their own
hotel if you were like a revolve
influencer you were totally taken care
of but there's only like 50 people yeah
max if you got invited to the festival
in any other way either by purchasing a
ticket i know they were like using
promoters in la any other way you were
told to show up to this like abandoned
field in the middle of the desert for a
shuttle to take you and nobody knew
where the party was so they had to rely
on these shuttles
and apparently what happened is like the
buses never came people were standing
outside in a field in 100 degrees
fainting there was no water no shade no
food and no one there being like here's
what's going on it was just kind of a
chaotic mess of like hundreds and
hundreds of influencers like stranded in
a desert okay but i saw footage from
like and everyone's saying revolve
festival fire festival and i just as
someone who's like watching it from a
distance like i'm sorry no it's not like
they put on a festival there were
thousands of people there so if you're
saying only like the hotel revolve
people
were able to go straight there and
everyone else had to take buses that
means they did bust in thousands of
people to get there and apparently like
the revolve verbiage to the people who
were there was like show up on time
and
i think one or two maybe three hours
after you were told to show up it became
chaos at the shuttle station got it and
i mean it's hard because things go viral
on tick tock and like people take such
pleasure in this like take down culture
and it's people just like live for the
shot in freud and
i'm just like not feeling it on this one
like yes that is such a [ __ ] bummer
to have to wait there and but they did
have buses and they did have
infrastructure and the festival was
happening and plenty of people got there
definitely way more than they bargained
for but they oversold and at a certain
point like if you can't get on the bus
or the bus isn't coming like you go to
the festival now we all saw that one
girl who came to palm springs just to go
to revolve festival she didn't even buy
tickets to she's the video who's going
viral oh i didn't see sorry i'm not sure
okay she like was explaining her
experience she was invited to revolve
festival probably got the email she's an
influencer and waited all day for the
shuttle from one o'clock to seven
o'clock and couldn't get on because the
people who were getting on were the
beasts right like she was like and like
that's not her style and she didn't even
buy tickets to coachella she only came
to palm springs to go to the revolt
festival she said like she missed easter
with her family because like she was
going to do this and like i'm sorry but
that's on you like people have choices
and you chose that and like sure it's
such it sucks that that's how your
weekend turned out and like yeah in a
perfect world you would have everything
would have been you know organized too
like that's what happens when
thousands of people want to go to
revolve festival so here's where i think
revolve is culpable okay you cannot make
someone pay for a ticket to an event
that they can't get it did they pay for
tickets i believe some of them did okay
because up until you just saying this to
me i assume revolve festival is free so
another video that i saw was like there
were four lines
for the shuttles one two three and four
and they all had different
tiers i guess and i think and they said
for the first couple hours only people
from line one were getting on the buses
i have to imagine that those were people
who paid
you don't think those people with the
most followers i don't know see that's
the thing and like i don't know what
revolve is valuing but i just know for a
fact that there are people who paid for
an event and weren't able to go and like
that is [ __ ] up and that's like
criminal
yeah that's [ __ ] up but i'm i've been
operating under the premise that it is
free because it's always been free so
i'm not 100 sure then but i agree like
you and i haven't seen any tick tocks or
anything but i only saw a few that said
that they paid so
i agree like you out of your own
volition spent your own time like
waiting for event and it clearly wasn't
gonna happen and you decided to stay
there like that is on you
um and that's like your choice but i
also think and i've always felt this way
like when at coachella like
the whole environment not even revolving
just coachella in general like feels
just like dangerously close to an
emergency like it's in the desert it's
so hot it's so remote there's a shortage
of cabs a shortage of everything because
yeah how do i springs is not designed to
have hundreds of thousands of people
flocking to it for four days so the
whole event feels like dangerously close
to like something bad happening it's so
hot it's it's on everyone's drinking
which dehydrates you it's always just
felt to me like a little scary um
and i agree like if if this was
and i wish i knew more logistics on like
the paying verse than not but if it's
like a totally free event that you
wanted to go to and you weren't able to
go to and you decided to spend five
hours standing in the hot that is on you
but also keep in mind like i can't
imagine it was easy to get an uber out
of that shuttle station no no it's hard
to get uber out of coachella right it's
just hard in general in general so i
think there there is responsibility on
revolve like
for having knowing that many people were
going to show up at a shuttle station
and not having the infrastructure to get
all those people there and maybe that's
what they wanted they wanted to create
hype and make it like exclusive and and
then they got to capacity and like no
one could come um so i think like when
you're encouraged when you're having
people show up in 100 degree heat in the
middle of the day with no water no
shelter and then not even buses showing
up like there's all buses and they were
coach buses too so i saw videos with
buses but like people were saying these
were literally the only buses that came
over the four or five hour period that i
was there okay so then how did the
thousands of people that i saw at
revolve festival malone get there i
believe those people were on time to
this shuttle station got it but again
you really can't know unless you were
there i guess they could have said to
everyone like we're at capacity like go
home please go home
i think also what i saw was like there
were people there
like security quote unquote who were
supposed to be like counselors who were
supposed to be organizing everyone and
they weren't doing anything but it's
also like you see the behavior of all of
these swarms of people who are like
there's no containing them no i agree
like there is an amount of personal
liability on the people who decided to
stand out there for six hours to see
post malone like you it's not jail like
you could leave um you could go to the
festival you could go back to your house
you could go get water you could go to a
restaurant go to taco bell have a soda
like there's
revolve is culpable in the sense that
like there it seemed like their event
was chaotic
not the event the event itself the
logistics around the event were chaotic
the the transporting people there but
also there's where's the personal
liability for like you deciding not to
spend easter with your family not to get
coachella tickets just to fly across the
country and miss the holiday to spend
one day at revolve festival which if
you've ever seen it like it's just a
content farm like right yeah i think a
lot of times it is more fun than it
actually looks but it it it's not like a
real no it's it's a content farm that's
the perfect like you walk around there's
sick things happening and no one's
really paying attention they're taking
pictures like you go on the rides to
take a picture and like because
everybody's really working yeah you know
and it's not in any negative way i
actually think like considering
everybody's working on it is like just a
photo op it's actually more fun than a
classic work event right but
no that's what you chose to do i agree
with what you're saying there's
liability um on everyone like you you
made that decision to stand with all
these people and trust me if it were me
like i would be so [ __ ] pissed like
and i don't know if i would make a tick
tock or an instagram story like because
it's like embarrassing that i decided to
like thirst out so hard stand like with
all these people when clearly it wasn't
happening like go to correct your house
yeah
yeah or if you're gonna come to the
desert for a weekend like make a weekend
out of it out of it get coachella
tickets have options yeah because
coachella weekend is all about trying to
get into parties that you might not get
into right for everyone unless you're
kim kardashian right
right now it's true it's true
we've been there we've been there oh
been been there big time i mean i don't
think anything on the scale as big as no
no no but like the frustration like even
if you guys weren't waiting at a
designated location even if you're
waiting outside the actual party right
like the bouncers right you could they
can only let so many people in it would
have been a different like the same
situation even if you're just waiting
outside the griffin estate right right
right it's just [ __ ] chaos everywhere
no and i think like the real reason why
people are pissed is because where they
were told to wait and ended up waiting
for so many hours was in the middle of
the day high heat no shade in the desert
no water the desert
no you know tents for them to stand
under like i saw a tent you did yeah i
saw a ten oh i didn't see a tent
what i was told is like there's no shade
no water no resources
so leave that's the point leave and
it'll take you a long time to leave but
like deciding to stand there for six
hours your tent
oh tent yes tent
um
deciding to stand there for six hours
that's on you yeah that's and maybe not
what you want to hear but that is on you
like wanting like the desperation to get
into reveal fest so
that's what you did
and it's just it's not fire festival
right no because the festival itself the
event where the ground the grounds where
the event were actually happening was a
smash post malone jack harlow food
drinks carnival rides thousands of
people it was but they they oversold the
event yeah okay and i'm just learning
how the tickets were sold because up
until now or some there was some sort of
like money exchange i just thought it
was for a lot of people yeah but also i
think people are also pissed because
like kim was there and clearly like they
probably paid her yeah and so it's like
they have all this money
for things like that but they are not
paying for more buses but i think that's
water at the transports but that's also
like the core one of the core tenants of
like nightlife and partying is like
exclusivity yeah so if a party if
everyone can go to a party it ain't that
cool yeah so that's just like a
marketing strategy
yeah
so i think revolve is definitely like
liable in some regards but i think also
it's important that every person who
decided to stay
six hours in the sun when they knew they
probably weren't getting to the party
like
and we're just desperate to be at
revolve fest like there needs to be
personal liability taken accountability
and how long would you have waited
me i'm really not good in the heat but
it would have been the both of us so
like i would have made you wait 20
minutes
20 minutes i think
no knowing me like i'm a bovan i would
have found out where the party was like
took an uber straight to the party and
like hopped hop defense well that's the
thing i wonder if you have if you took
an uber straight to the party like if
you could walk into the party they were
very um intentional about not letting
people know where it was and we know
where it was because we've been there
twice before but most people don't know
where the actual grounds are yeah so if
they wanted to take an uber straight
there they wouldn't even know what
address to put in the location okay but
if you knew the address could you walk
through the door where you had to come
in through a bus i think you could have
walked through the door but once you got
to the door you were told that they were
at capacity depend like it just depends
on who you are and they give out
wristbands of different colors for
different tiers like if you have a
certain wrist brand you can get into the
private club area if you have a certain
other color wristband you just get to
walk the grounds so i think depending on
what wristband you had if they were at
capacity if you had like a really
special wristband they would let you in
but once they were at capacity you just
have the regular general admission
wristband it was like nah got it okay
but you're right it is a free event for
most people i think
um
which means that not everyone is going
to get
to come and i mean the idea the what
you're telling me about the coachella
festival being at capacity and people
just being able to get in
that's [ __ ] up yes i heard that too
that coachelli
um was turning people away especially
the first night because harry's
stage
crowd size had like one of the biggest
in coachella history wow it looked great
his performance it looked amazing shania
twain was there um it was everything of
the such an interesting choice like you
bring out one person in the chennai
tween here for completely
it's actually not that interesting if
you like our one direction harry stan
like he has been obsessed with should i
train forever
um
you're still the one is like one of his
favorite songs when he was on tour with
uh casey musgraves she opened for him
every night she would come back out and
sing that song like a duet really
beautiful harmony with him it's like one
of his favorite songs
so he's like a shania girly cute and i
thought it was like the perfect
the perfect collab yeah no people were
living for it and it was so good she
killed it olivia wilde was there too
like frolicking around the field in her
fur coat also it felt like very low on
celebrities this year yes like it used
to be like a celebrity playground like
so you should spot them everywhere like
now of course there's influencers and
there were a handful of like traditional
celebrities but a lot less than usual
yeah it was just like haley
kardashian and that's because justin
performed peaches with uh
daniel caesar at the um at his per at
his
during his set and also the kardashians
were there because they always do
eastern pumpkins and like eight one
eight was that revolves so it was just
like let's check out the festival there
was a limited showing from like a-list
talent yeah there's usually like so many
models vanessa hudgens where was she oh
yeah cacelli gurley the coachella queen
totally you know
um all in all i was just like really
living for the content in terms of
influencers and their looks i think like
honestly everyone looked stupid except
for um shannon ford looked amazing
she is that girl so she has no choice
but to be that girl
i thought sophia la court looked great i
thought sylvia court looked amazing and
that's really it i thought the sabotage
girls looked so cute and sophie sutan
was my best dress of the whole week
agreed did i oh and day three i just saw
it was sickening as well it had like a
butterfly top yeah but overall just like
everyone was like doing the most trying
the hardest and overall like at a glance
looking at the event you know from a
bird's-eye perspective it was a bunch of
like losers being losers you know
and like and
and if you've been there like you just
know it's even more loser in person you
know yeah yes and no because like every
time we've been we actually have like a
genuinely good time that's us like we we
are not content we like to take one
picture and then we're tired we're like
okay can we please like just enjoy it
and you know what and if we weren't
having a good time we would leave right
and like we we just know how to have fun
like we found pot we we were just like
the first for the first time ever we
were like should we smoke like we were
like saying should be too acid we were
like should we smoke pot
i mean it's so much fun like we really
enjoyed the festival we didn't do like a
ton of parties and so i think there's
definitely a way to have a lot of fun at
coachella but i just think with each
year that passes it becomes more and
more of like a work obligation yeah and
less and less fun which is why
stagecoach is the weekend to go yeah
there's no parties like
corporate greed it's just i also feel
like in the past there have been so many
competing parties during the day and i
feel like most other brands have given
up now yeah it's been like revolved
taking the wheels or a lot of brands
activate at revolve like every single
station is branded and those brands are
paying for the event i'm sure revolve
spends a lot less money than people yeah
totally and they always have sponsors
like when we the last time we were there
um
what's that food delivery
doordash was like the number one sponsor
they've tons of sponsors you're right
it's definitely an expensive party to
throw and they definitely spend a couple
million dollars but not of their money
specifically yes
no i think they spend a couple million
dollars of their own money specifically
but the whole event in its entirety
costs 20 million with all the performers
the grounds the food the liquor
everything the carnival rides it's
pleasant i mean hotel hotel oh and then
also paying the girls the girls the
influencers like the top tier
influencers who actually get to go with
revolve paying them it's a very
expensive event but they don't pay for
all of it yeah i think a lot less than
people would think yeah
so it was just very interesting it
wasn't everything outside in the desert
is recovered and is really thinking
about their choices
i agree
i agree but because you know what at the
end of the day revolve totally liable
but you did stand out there for all
those hours knowing you probably weren't
going to make it like you did do that
you did and for what so you get an
instagram like that's where right that's
where our values are society like our
priorities are [ __ ] out of whack yeah
i agree out of [ __ ] hungary go home
for easter go home
are you ready for our next story you
feel coachella doubt two other
performances that stood out to you no
like all megan the stallion's
performance looked amazing just from
like stocking tick tock all maybe i got
into a rut because i watched so much
harry content i was only served harry
content got it that's all i saw oh and
of course like harry content we [ __ ]
love and right did you know that his new
album is called harry's
i'm gonna have house
buy all the merch uh so apparently the
merch coachella was so sick did anyone
get me anything bring it to claudia's
meet and greet you can find it on
poshmark for one million dollars i drank
out of my rey dog
mug this morning i [ __ ] need to take
a picture i do feel different i just
want to say like i understand why we're
all laughing at raytan but i also
understand the love and the hype of
course like it's it's so cute do you
want more like kind don't get crazy but
like if you guys are thinking like would
jackie want ray done that to bring to
the meet and greet like yeah okay no
i'll like i [ __ ] with it i'll do some
searching it's just it was and zack saw
my monkeys like what a cute mug got that
for you it's like not you
[Laughter]
i said the toasters um so yeah i'm i'm
feeling this right she's a rage on
girlie ray done girly yes okay switching
gears completely because rihanna would
never
the influencer blogger is apologizing
for the reckless rihanna and asap rocky
rumor that started last week so
that didn't start that he started he
started that like everyone just believed
that got so much press but this person
like we never i never heard of um and
now it's like completely untrue yeah of
course and like i just hate [ __ ] like
this like first of all i hate that as a
society we just like believe what random
people on the internet say yeah
especially when when i was reporting on
this last week i've never heard of this
influencer but his claim to fame is like
vogue or paper magazine referred to him
as the messiest fashion influencer on
the internet right now so like he's
known for being like a menace and we all
just believed in like these are real
people i just hate this [ __ ] these are
real people she is so pregnant like who
needs this and they're back in barbados
now i think she's probably going to give
birth that's what i saw which is so cute
they seem to be very happy i like hate
this man yeah well he's apologizing he
said last night i made a dumb decision
to tweet some information i had received
i'm not going to talk about sources
blame others for discussion that was
started because at the end of the day i
made the decision to drop that tweet
press send and put that out with my name
on it i'd like to formally apologize to
all parties i involved with my actions
and for my reckless tweets this is like
so embarrassing and to the general
public who hadn't heard of this guy like
this is going to be our association with
him for a very long time and now i just
like if i ever read anything with his
name in it i'm just going to be like
liar credibility is shocking out the
window and especially with like a
pregnant woman like you just don't do
that like you can't now she's probably
like so stressed like it's just
for rihanna like she's
fine you know but like to say you heard
this rumor and say whether or not it was
true or not like to put that out there
when she is like so pregnant it's just
what's what are you trying to achieve
you know and the rumor got like so far
as to amina mawadi having to having to
put out a scene right right so it wasn't
nothing it wasn't harmless like it was
hard it caused harm it was harmful full
of harm full of it and these are just
people who i don't think deserve harm no
don't get me wrong there are definitely
people out there who deserve harm like i
have a whole list
rihanna asap and amina mawadi are not
those people no they are not and i just
hate people whose like
claim to fame on the internet is like
just starting stuff yeah and then seeing
a lot of that recently because you get
rewarded for it in this culture like you
become famous your lies become facts
like people are upset like we live in
this moronic culture where we just
believe everything we read so people
like this guy i'm not even sure of his
name are gonna become like sources yeah
so one random guy says something on the
internet i say [ __ ] all the time no one
listens to me like why now no why this
rumor it's that it's like just making
[ __ ] up about people which we see a lot
but it's also like this just like
complain culture which brings it back to
the revolve fest of like just something
didn't go your way you're gonna complain
about it like and everyone is just gonna
live for it and i'm just not really even
if your gripe is valid legitimate yeah
but this is completely illegitimate you
can't just make stuff up about people
yeah and you know what if rihanna wanted
to like she probably has grounds to sue
for libel mm-hmm because you just make
some random [ __ ] [ __ ] up and press
end yeah where is the accountability
yeah and i never want people to get sued
but i do think it would like set a
precedent for like the next time some
tick tocker is like yeah i had sex with
kanye west you might think twice you
might think twice you might still do it
but you didn't you might have thought
twice yeah
are you ready for our next story yeah uh
no you're not ready i don't think you're
ready i mean is it the story that's
brought to you by frame bridge every
story is brought to us by friends if you
want to frame your dog stool sample or
any other precious memory check out
frame bridge here's how it works they
are the easier and more affordable way
to frame your favorite things and you
never have to leave your house so
whether it's art prints diplomas photos
in your phone you can frame bridge just
about anything and with mother's day
around the corner they make the perfect
gift
how it works is you go to
framebridge.com upload your photo
directly from your phone or they can
send you packaging if you have a
physical photo you want to mail you'll
preview your item online in dozens of
frame styles and gallery wall layouts
choose your favorite or get free
recommendations from their talented
designers and then the experts at frame
bridge will custom frame your item
deliver your finished piece to your door
and it'll be ready to hang instead of
the hundreds you'd pay at the framing
store their prices start at just 39
and all shipping is free plus our
listeners will get 15 off their first
order at framebridge.com when you use
the code toast they also have in-person
stores now where you can work with some
of their sickening designers in new york
dc atlanta philly boston and chicago so
if there's something on your phone that
you just want to get off and frame if
you think you have a nice photo of you
and your mom for mother's day or
something she might like get started
today frame your photos or send someone
the perfect gift at framebridge.com and
you can use the promo code toast to save
an additional 15 off on your first order
framebridge.com promo code toast
framebridge.com promo code toast love it
our girly jessica simpson is saying she
loves her body at every size after
weight loss queen
doing queen things yeah jessica simpson
is a queen so she did an interview and
there are just like so many precious
quotes that i want to share the singer
who has lost 100 pounds three separate
times said in a new interview that she
has the experience to understand women
and what they want out of life and their
clothes she said i understand the
mentality of all women and i understand
loving where you're at or wanting more
or wanting something better i understand
that she said she had to grapple with
weight struggles all in the public eye
but finally has gotten to a place where
she is comfortable and amazed in her
skin she said i always celebrate my body
the fact that i made children is unreal
she said of her three kids but you just
don't ever think you're going to fit
back into things i feel you girl it's
crazy a woman's body is phenomenal in
what it can do she recently shared a
photo of herself wearing a bikini to
flaunt her figure and credited her
results to hard work determination and
self-love she admitted that she cried
tears of joy at reaching the milestone
after having been devastated by her size
at the end of her pregnancies she said
that she threw out her scale following
years of body image struggles after she
had her kids i just loved my soul right
now i just you know if i had to get
married again which i hope to never do
you would marry jessica simpson no i
think that like i really do believe she
no one on the planet understands a
woman's body better than her like i
would have her make my wedding dress
like if that was an option okay i would
also marry her if that was an option i
just didn't know where you were going
with it um but no i think this is all
like i think all that a lot of the
interviews she does right now is to
promote her as like a a designer because
you know she now owns 100 of her jessica
simpson collection company and so that's
very much like her priority and it's
true like when i think of buying
clothing like i want to buy it from
someone like jessica simpson who's been
all sizes who knows what you need at a
bigger size or at a smaller size and
just because you need bigger sizes you
have to wear an ugly [ __ ] smock dress
like like i would like i trust this
woman with my life i totally agree
i take a bullet for her you would take a
lot of bullets that's me but i really
and i i say that as like a euphemism but
with jessica simpson it's 100 facts it
really is just when you think like she
she's been kind of quiet recently and
ever since like the fanfare from us from
over her book like
i just i love everyone i love like every
few months like a re-upping of jessica
simpson's stanhood and especially now
when she's like speaking directly to me
about what it feels like to postpone be
sure if your clothes are ever gonna fit
again and honestly reading this just
gives me like more hope and patience is
really what requires like i'm not trying
to be hard on myself or anything but
like a girl's gotta dress girl's got to
eat like a girl's gotta be close yeah
right no i completely agree i think
jessica simpson is all of us like she's
truly
like a woman of the people she's an
american woman you know
i just love this queen with every fiber
of my being following her on instagram
she gives off britney spears vibes with
like a lot of emojis and a lot of like
unique angles but we live for it we live
for it it's not completely comfortable
she does like no no i said i didn't say
it was the same as it gives off a little
bit of the energy okay i yeah i feel
that but you just can't just tell she's
excited about what she's posting i just
love her like she and she always gives
us a glimpse she lives this just lavish
life she just recently posted about a
birthday party for one of her kids that
i forget the theme but it was like
something themed and she went all out it
was like a beautiful party at her
property in malibu like it was
she gets like overlooked a lot i think
because she's not so in the public eye
anymore but when we think of like
celebrities we want to you know switch
lives for a day like you need to see
that house yeah she like people forget
like she's rich yeah rich rich
love that for her and i'm like you know
80 happy like 20 jealous that's healthy
for you yeah okay like 70 30 but yeah
still healthy 60 40.
are you ready for our next story the
drama which i have yet to discuss with
you but i know you talked about it a few
times and elon musk trying to buy
twitter and the twitter
board is now adopting a poison pill plan
to thwart elon from buying twitter for
the proposed 43 billion dollar takeover
that he is trying to enact and tell me
what a poison pill is because you know i
have no idea so basically they are
trying to
get other people to buy more shares by
devaluing the price of their stock
therefore like diluting it's literally
like the gilded age
yeah is that what he did
when those you know church elders tried
to oust him
no he bought up all his stock because he
could right right but i don't know it's
getting similar i don't think that these
board members can if you've seen the
list of board members and how much talk
they own aside from jack the initial
founder not one of them owns more than
one percent elon is now at nine percent
yeah so i don't like fully understand
the economics behind all of this but i
do it's a lot but here's what i
understand i understand simple like
business logic and i understand that
twitter is beyond irrelevant as a
platform i don't think they generate a
lot of revenue and i just think in the
social ecosystem like they're literally
the worst app everyone would agree you
know kids coming of age and social media
have every single social media app
except for twitter
so here is a guy for whatever his own
reasons are like wants to give you 50
billion dollars for your irrelevant
stupid app take it like that's the money
in business but the thing is they don't
want the money they want control and
they want power and they want the
ability to
content moderate censor what goes on on
twitter and elon wants the opposite so i
just feel like for me like money is
always gonna win and if i was a
shareholder i'd be like [ __ ] this i want
out of this loser company the thing is
like at a certain point if they continue
to like make bad financial decisions on
behalf of the shareholders it is a
public company shareholders can sue
right but they would literally rather
get into that mess than let eon take the
wheel and what is elon's plan for
twitter like just for like he's been
like running all these funny polls on
his uh things about changes that he
would make like things like an edit
button right which is now coming but in
general he wants free speech so i think
the plan would be to be a little more
hands-off
and then also um what else was he asking
people if they would want
like just tweaks to the to the platform
to the platform like different features
yeah yeah i mean i can't
like i really don't understand because
for me like i'm always gonna lead with
money like whatever decision is gonna
make me the most money and that's just
me being a smart business woman and
maybe these like you know close-minded
shareholders i can't see my vision but
my vision leads with green and i just
don't understand like i would be
embarrassed to be on the twitter board
because like it's like the loseriest
company and i can't imagine you make a
lot of money from being especially if
you're like turning down money at least
right so like someone comes like let's
say oh this is like for me this is the
analogy like i'm on this sinking ship
and i'm gonna die and someone was like
here you want a life wrapped i'm like
nah right like i don't understand
because for me i'm always going to take
the 43 billion dollars but maybe i'm
just not like other girls maybe you're
not like other board members i'm not
like other investors that's for me i'm
sure no i think it's them who are not
like other investors yeah i think most
investors are interested in the green in
generally speaking you know people
really don't like elon musk and i know
like billionaires are not you know
universally loved but um i was seeing
some stuff going on on twitter just like
different reactions to when jeff bezos
bought the washington post and i didn't
even know that he owned the washington
post the newspaper um and everyone was
like woohoo and then elon wants my
twitter and like it's bad so i don't
really understand but that's i think
just people's like
biases yeah so for me i just don't
understand like not wanting 43 billion
dollars that's kind of where my head is
stuck
yeah and i don't understand not wanting
to give the reins to elon like
everything he touches turns to gold it's
true he's the richest man on the planet
no i don't want your help like couldn't
be me it couldn't be couldn't be me go
maybe elon if elaine isn't elon
if elon is in the business of purchasing
media companies like we are for sale
we are for sale but i think because one
thing about me
is i can be bought 100 100 but i don't
know what elon would even want to do
with us like i think he would be like
and plus we
we speak so glowingly about him yeah he
would literally be like here's 43
billion dollars keep doing what you're
doing that i could agree to no that's a
deal so i just wanted to put it out
there because he's obviously just like
writing checks
we are for sale we can be bought yes we
can and we will say whatever you want us
to say because tesla's are the best cars
on the planet and all these billionaires
who want to go to space no one does it
quite like elon and he's so handsome and
just the perfect father and a wonderful
person so we would like 43 billion
dollars thank you where's the lie though
43 billion please
where's the lie are you ready for our
fifth and final story a little cargo
news
cargo pants no like cargo ships
yeah evergreen's like sister ship got
stuck in chesapeake bay and everybody's
breaking and it's like everyone wants to
recreate the magic of the suez but it's
not you can't you can't you can't even
have evergreen got stuck in the suez
again it wouldn't be the same it
wouldn't be the same all of these
copycats try as you may and i know that
this guy got stuck in the chesapeake on
purpose because he wanted attention and
i'm just saying we're not giving you the
attention you will never be suez you
will never be 2020 evergreen moment
you're a fraud you are fake no matter
how many chanel bags you borrow you will
never be a lady hundred percent these
copycats have got to quit it and also
you're [ __ ] with our cargo now you
know now it's not funny like you wanted
attention but like now you know like we
could say supply chain we could
sacrifice what was on that ship because
the suez situation brought us together
of course but this now you're just
messing with people's furniture orders
you're messing with the supply chain and
the supply chain is already fractured
like stop it's not the vibe yeah like so
suddenly you know for centuries everyone
has known how to drive a cargo boat but
up until this year it's like everyone
forgot
thirsty [ __ ] cargo ships attention
[ __ ] stop
well after weeks of tugging pulling
digging and dumping the 1095-foot cargo
ship ever forward was pried from the
muddy clutches of the chesapeake bay on
sunday morning so
energy
loser energy like stop we see right
through you and all your antics this is
not what we need and this is not what we
were referring to no and like these
things have to be organic and it's just
sales planned no it's giving
it's giving fraudulence it is
and try as you may like you will never
be the evergreen suez moment but keep
trying sweetie yeah actually don't keep
trying okay because some of us are
waiting for our furniture deliveries for
seven months and like you're [ __ ]
with it 100
100 and i feel as though nice try though
and i i feel like
maybe they got confused because like for
example we were so here for the swez
moment like it was my favorite story of
2020. same and so maybe they thought
they were giving us more and i just
needed to let everyone know and put that
in there to let you guys know to stop it
is not the vibe yeah it's just like it's
giving loser and that's on you being a
loser so that's something you have to
live with i'm gonna move on with my life
and i'm gonna unburden myself there's a
lot of things that are giving a loser
today i know oh my god but like that's
ever since um what was that story that
we initially started loser energy
caroline calloway right there was like
that big influencer scandal and i don't
really remember what happened but
was writing her captions and then the
girl like wrote an expose about it and
everyone was like the girl and it just
seemed like everyone girl included like
was being losers it was loser on loser
crime and once you just kind of look at
the world in like every situation as
just really seeing like the true loser
energy within every person you will feel
so free yeah and like looking at every
situation like if you were sitting on
your couch this weekend being like oh my
wish is that coachella just see them all
as losers and everything will change
everything
has changed with that i think we should
unburden ourselves please so unburden
yourselves is our monday segment where
you can write in and burden yourself
with something embarrassing you did over
the weekend and we're just gonna help
you feel better about it we're not gonna
try and change you we're just gonna take
that burden and
squash
so
release it thank you um
you can write in to unburden yourselves
at unburden yourselves gmail.com and it
is always anonymous and we're just going
to help you on that burden
and
unburden yourselves is brought to you by
bullen branch the number one best sheets
on the planet i've got them all
are you guys okay we're going to take
that burden and
the best 100 organic cotton threads on
earth for superior softness and a better
night's sleep their sheets aren't just
buttery breathable and impossibly soft
to start but they get softer with every
watch so i have the signature hem sheets
i have them in white for my king size
bed and it is their best seller for a
reason
they use the highest quality threads on
earth they're made with luxurious
threads that they have even been beloved
by three us presidents they feel buttery
to the touch and are super breathable so
they're perfect for every season bowl
and branch signature sheets come in nine
versatile colors and in all sizes so
that's twin up to california king and
you'll immediately feel the difference
in their iconic signature sheets they
also offer other products like i have
the waffle throw it's everything of the
sort and best of all bolin branch gives
you a 30-day 30-night risk-free trial
with free shipping and returns on all
orders if you miss the bowling branch
april april sale our listeners can get
exclusive access to a post sale 20 off
site wide discount through the end of
april with the promo code toast at
bowlingbranch.com that's bowlin branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com promo code toast for 20
off through the end of april
okay first girly girl is unburdening
herself after an uncomfortable dinner
with her in-laws hi ladies long time
listener first time unburdener this past
weekend i was with my boyfriend's family
for easter one of the nights we went out
to dinner it was a nicer restaurant so i
wore a cute little sundress the city we
were in is hot but the restaurant was
freezing and i didn't bring a sweater
and my dress was strapless throughout
the meal my boyfriend's mom kept
offering me her sweater and it was
really sweet of her but it was so cold
in the restaurant i kept declining
because i felt bad that she'd be cold
she offered several times but i declined
for a while i ended up going to the
bathroom and as i look in the mirror
while washing my hands i noticed that my
nipples are beaming through my dress
like full blown high beams i could have
taken someone's eye out if they got too
close i immediately wanted to die
because then it occurred to me that my
boyfriend's sweet mother definitely saw
and was offering the sweater to help me
out and i stupidly declined i put all my
hair in front of him
in front of my face to cover my nips for
the rest of the evening and i prayed no
one else saw of course i texted my
boyfriend from the table and he was
cracking up meanwhile i was melting in
my own embarrassment feels good to get
that off my chest literally signed a
nippy not so toasty toaster listen
you didn't know it's a part of life it's
also it's like not that embarrassing
it's not that embarrassing and i think
for the mom like she was clearly trying
to help and i think that you coming back
from the bathroom with your hair and
from your nipples like just showed oh my
god i just realized this is not who i
want to be and i'm sorry and i think
like the woman to woman signaling i feel
like she got that and this is why it's
important like never to cut your hair
below your above your nipples because
you never know when for me like my hair
is a protection i don't really get hard
nipples that much my nipples like don't
work that way
but i have like big face syndrome i
always have stains like spaghetti sauce
like right up here and having long hair
is such a security blanket and that's
why i'm just not here for like short
hair yeah i think also why this wouldn't
apply to us it's i feel like she was
wearing a sundress without a bra you
know which is if if you always have to
wear a bralette a luxury not all of us
are afforded there's more protection
yeah another layer right so that
wouldn't happen this isn't that bad
especially because
it seems like you're obviously trying to
impress your in-laws and she wasn't
being a [ __ ] about it she was like
genuinely trying to help so it seems
like you have a nice mother-in-law yeah
i think i think it's totally fine like
obviously not ideal not ideal and i
understand like wearing a sundress and
it's because it's hot outside you know
what i've recently done like the last
few summers that i would just like to
extend to everyone
try a
because you pashmina
want to ruin your outfit with a sweater
like it doesn't call for a sweater but
the restaurant can get really cold
sometimes it gets cold at night i've
been bringing a pashmina around in the
summer and it's such a vibe and it just
really elevates your look it's an
extremely elegant
rich nantucket mother thing to do it
really is you know she gets on her porch
she wraps her pashmina she contemplates
divorce
it's so chic but like anybody can wear a
pashmina so why don't we all no it's so
true pashminas are completely universal
and completely underrated so just get
one pashmina yeah they sell them on the
street in new york for like a dollar in
a color that works with any outfit in
the wash and it's good and then for the
next time you don't have to worry about
it so that's my tip of the day
i love you know what i'm thinking
pashminas hey let's fold pashminas i
would love to all right next up hello
jackson claude love you both so much as
avid music lovers and concert goers i
hope you can understand where i'm coming
from when i tell you about the most vile
thing i did last week i was at a justin
bieber concert and i had floor seats
that were incredible i'm a belieber for
life so this wasn't just any concert for
me about a third of the way through the
concert i finished my drink and all of a
sudden i had a shooting pain in my
stomach since i had such amazing seats
leaving to go to the bathroom would
simply not be an option because i knew
someone would have taken it by the time
i got back so rationally while everyone
around was getting their soul snatched
by biebs i squatted down and i peed in
my cup in the middle of the concert in
the middle of the concert as soon as the
show ended the people started shuffling
out and i heard someone yell it smells
like piss and puss down here
i got out unscathed but i kindly asked
to unburden myself for my unhinged
behavior that's insane that's disgusting
like
i'm all for public urination i really am
like not near other people because you
know your all of our fluids carry
different bacteria diseases like i just
don't think it's nice to be peeing in
front of other other people and not to
be that girl but like imagine if a guy
next to you like put my dad his penis
and started peeing like it's gross yeah
like it's traumatizing
yeah that's like really crazy also it
feels even
not to make you feel worse because you
obviously already feel that's why you
feel worse and like you did and you got
away with it for the most part so it is
what it is i have like so many different
thoughts about it and also it's just
reminding me like i saw this headline of
kim kardashian saying on ellen that like
she'll do anything for fashion like even
wear something if she has to wear a
diaper with it like maybe if you're this
kind of girl who can't miss a song to
pee
wear a diaper to the concert well i am
that that type of girl but you know i
have this gift it's really i don't think
i've ever spoken about this gift
uh like at a concert i always pee like
i'm the girl who pees three times during
a movie and it's because i i think i
think i don't know the medical reason
but i think it's because my fupa weighs
like really heavy on my bladder and it's
just like science
um so i am that girl like and i always
i'm having like cocktail after cocktail
so drinking makes you pee i i am that
girl like i will be sorry that's duh
true but alcohol alcohol i am that girl
like i will pee multiple times during an
event and i have this gift and i guess
like i'm not a ga girl like i'd rather
have the worst seat in the house than
stand ga during a concert you need to
know the gift that you have
i
can pee like i can get from my seat to
the bathroom and back in 30 seconds like
i will sprint i will pee so [ __ ] fast
and while i'm peeing i'm multitasking
i'm getting the toilet paper ready yeah
i'm just fixing my lipstick and yeah
sometimes i won't wash my hands and i'll
run back like i can get to and fro in
forty five seconds you're the one saying
like germs yeah you're concerned with
her germs being on the floor yeah but
you won't wash your hands like i'll grab
a little hand sanitizer on my way out
that's a good thing about copy there's
sanitizer everywhere okay that's fine
that's acceptable i just don't feel like
if you're going to pee three times in an
hour like wash your hands every time
at madison square garden yeah oh
speaking of madison square garden that
is where i will be may 5th for my final
comedy show yeah check it out girl with
no job.com
tour jackie will be there and this is
the first show she's seen because she
doesn't support my comedy card and i'm
totally kidding but it is the first show
she's gonna see so like experience that
with jackie yeah i'm so excited i
actually just ordered a potential outfit
i need to do that and i hope it works
because it's exactly what like i need to
be wearing like something that would be
like flat running and also like cleaning
i love you is it a suit what is it it's
a dress because i have respect for the
arts and no it's like we're going to the
theater like let's all dress up and pay
respect to the queen who we're seeing a
hundred percent i'm just back to the
justin bieber things yeah one other
thought also at like a justin bieber
concert there's really like a lot of
kids so that just also makes it worse
like it's like you're at a festival
where everyone pisses and shits on the
ground it's true like know your audience
it's true and it's just not acceptable
and i'm sorry that i have to be the one
to say that i know and like i know you
already feel bad because you know to get
to a point where you're emailing us
about something embarrassing you did
like it's a low point for sure so i
don't want to make you feel better worse
but it's not good it's not good and all
i'll say is just don't do it again don't
do it again we can forgive
once right just don't do it again i want
to forgive you and i want to forget you
and if you feel the need to do it again
wear a diaper like i was in diapers for
the past few weeks and they're kind of
incredible yeah but you weren't like
peeing on yourself were you no like if
you had to pee you weren't like oh i'm
wearing a diaper let me just pee in my
diaper no you went down but i better i
would rather pee in my diaper than pee
on the floor at a concert yeah no
honestly so for her i would rather miss
one song right but she wouldn't no but
also logistically she's on the floor
like it does take a long time in an
arena to get like up because the
bathroom there's no floor bathrooms yeah
you should walk up the stairs it's a lot
different i understand diaper diaper
all right our third and final one
claudia and jackie i'm still so
mortified about this on saturday my
boyfriend and i were doing the most
wholesome thing oh i read this one
before it's disgusting
on saturday my boyfriend and i were
doing the most wholesome thing on
saturday evening
for a couple in their 20s we decided to
have dinner with his grandparents and
then hanging out but beautiful
um on the way over to their house i
decided to spice things up a bit and
give my boyfriend roadhead
obviously my hands were involved as i'm
trying not to puke lol and i just
planned to go to the bathroom and wash
my hands shortly after arriving not to
be gross
i kid you not a minute after i walk in
the door his grandma was raving about
this new mustard she ordered online and
how i must try it immediately i tried to
excuse myself to run to the restroom but
she was dead set so she opens up this
jar of mustard and is like just dip your
finger in and try it much in my dismay i
obliged and dipped my bj covered finger
in her mustard jar i am mortified by the
fact that her mustard now has remnants
of her grandson's [ __ ] in it i can't
even bring myself to tell my boyfriend
that this happened
well that's just unfortunate it's really
unfortunate um
and moment of silence for grandma's
mustard yeah
yeah um okay
you need to go over to grandma's house
find the mustard you need to go to
church you need to go to jail and repent
you need to go over to grandma's house
find the mustard throw it away grandma
cannot be using this mustard no you also
need to like write down the name of the
mustard and buy her new one and maybe
just swap it out and just pray that in
the time that the delivery takes she
doesn't have to use it but also like
gran insisting that you stick your
finger in her mustard in a pandemic is a
little crazy i just feel like you could
have tried harder i agree to wash your
hands because if she's like dip your
finger in it's like oh wait i just took
an uber so let me just wash my hands
before i just feel like you really could
have tried harder it's not like she had
a gun to your head she grabbed your
wrist and took your finger and dipped it
right you could have tried but harder
everyone is responsible everyone is
culpable but you especially you knew and
grant didn't know i i didn't know
and you knew
i just really feel like you didn't try
your best to wash your hands before
dipping your fingers and where was your
boyfriend he knew right where was he he
could have blocked i just he could have
said i'll try the mustard grant right he
could have said use my finger like it's
clean whatever yeah i just feel like you
didn't try hard enough or you could have
like grabbed a fork like you there were
so many things you could have done to
avoid this and you didn't and that's on
you that's really circling back to
personal accountability that we were
talking about at the top of the show
yeah you could have done more and you
didn't and you put grant in harm's way
and that's not quality the ground is
reckless for sure but you know what at
least we're like you know boosting
grounds immunity hopefully
that's important immunity is important
it is
pray for gran's mustard her immune
system is just rock hard
with grandkids like you
who needs enemies
um okay well thank you for sharing
everyone y'all are crazy again if you
want to write please keep writing yeah
we'll try like
it's hard i try not to judge but these
girls made it hard
um if you want to write in again it's
unburdened you're selling
but just know now your burden has been
earned right you've been earned and
therefore you can be free and there's
really nothing better than being
underframed nothing at all
living under wild and free
that's my uh
that's my new theme song um so thank you
everyone for listening to today's
episode of the toast jackie it's been a
pleasure having you here getting all
your songs out because you didn't sing i
didn't sing once today and it really has
been a pleasure
doing business with you
thank you so much for being here
anything you want to say to the toasters
before you come back actually this week
is jackie's back two days a week now
we're getting gearing back up for
full-time jackie oh we are gearing back
up a lot of people are like please tell
me jackie's coming back full-time after
a lot of people i saw something even ben
was like is jackie coming i'm like are
you kidding me
um yes of course i saw some fake news
that was like when did we ever say we
always said like month three like
two months like regular work is three
months so break don't start coming for
me until it's month three and and i'm
still not and you're nowhere to be found
right but no we're revving it up i mean
it's definitely getting easier getting
here so that's good um yeah you got here
early today i'm just such an early bird
yes i woke up at the [ __ ] crack of
dawn and i just didn't go back to sleep
because i think it's harder to go back
to like wake up from like a 30 minute
spurt than it is to just stay up agreed
you know that's what i'm learning um
well thank you so much for being here
and this is the first day that i've come
into the studio where i did not get a
migraine from from
the adventure we're all winning here
today it's getting better thank you so
much for listening to the morning
christmas monday morning show where we
deliver the fastpass stories you need
each one every monday friday on youtube
so if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast and where
podcasts can be found so it's a spotify
itunes city public radio i hear video
catbox all the places you might be
listening to podcasts fine that's
morning just leave a five star view
about a beautiful sunny and more we are
have an amazing day you guys we'll see
you tomorrow with
ben in studio we've got a great week
remy bader is coming tasha's coming and
we're finishing the week off back with
jackie oh so we're just sandwiching
jackie beginning and end it's gonna be
great and we'll see you tomorrow love ya
bye